welcome to the talk all right we are so
excited today because we have some
really
big news
[Music]
okay we are so
thrilled to announce that
we are going to be joined by
amanda klutz and elaine welteros
and they will be joining the show as
our two new co-hosts and they will be
joining us
starting january 4th
so we couldn't be happier we've had
great times with them in the studio and
we hope that this will go on for a very
long time
[Applause]
well you know i have to say this process
obviously is a weird process because
it's like
still dating the dude while he's looking
for the next like girl
but i have to say get us through the
holiday stuff
yes i'll be here through the holidays
but i have to say
listen it's i think it's it's it's
amazing it's a great like it's exciting
it's a new chapter for everyone it's a
new chapter for everyone so yeah
and even your own family like this
family just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and we love you we love you but i
love you so much i do want to say that
like i'm excited i think they're both
such wonderful people and they both have
so much to bring and to offer and
the chemistry has been great and it just
feels good too
that's right yeah it feels right yeah
intelligent lovely
souls to be a different perspective yes
you you have a mother
who's starting her career you know so
you know
we you know need different energy and i
think elaine is very dynamic
you know she's got a very good spiritual
sense to her
and i think that it's a good fit for all
of us
[Music]
you